всіх вітаємо це Херсон де окупований
героїчними збройними силами України але
кожна вулиця кожний будинок кожне
місцина цього героїчного міста нагадують
про окупацію і весь день от поки ми тут
знаходилися Бог Колобок колобоккало тому
що росіяни які знаходяться буквально в
кілометрі за річкою не припиняються ці
свої спроби зламати дух українського
Херсона вражає мужність херсонців які
постійно повторюють так без світла так
без води так іноді без хліба без грошей
тому що немає роботи немає сьогодні тут
зарплат але головне без вас без вас
ненависна весня яка знищувала дух цього
українського міста ми бачимо наскільки
херсонці які пережили страшну окупацію
російськими військами наскільки вони
мужньо переносять і Ці випробування тому
що зараз роки хочуть знищити місто і
дотворити його на руїни місто зруйноване
і не так багато людей і дуже мало дітей
але ці діти що є звичайно серце за них
болить те що от кожну хвилину бахкає Да
ми з вами бачимо що дійсно вдень там
більше 90
обстрілів самого міста дуже багато
будівель а зруйнованих і от сьогодні цей
день коли ми з Іванкою і Марією приїхали
для того щоб завести гуманітарну
допомогу передати нашим військовим форм
зустрітися з нашою тут і молодіжкою і
справою громад які знаходилися в
окупації активісти херсонські
поспілкуватися почути Чим живе місто
прапор для меня
как сердце но в моем сердце продолжает
длится Наша команда я становила такі
намет гуманітарний де можна принаймні
коли відключається світло погрітися там
є буржуйка і є постійно гаряча вода щоб
випити чай каву там є багато-багато
розеток для того щоб підзарядити гаджети
і зв'язок це також дуже важливо приходи
мось гуляться
щоб до мене сидіти помалювати ми принесу
сюди всі різні там ну принадлежностей
намет нам потрібно для того щоб
заряджати телефони погрітися якщо немає
світла і коли немає тепла весь день поки
ми знаходилися в Херсоні тут було чутно
вибухи а гухкання
російсько-окупаційна армія яка
знаходиться буквально в кілометрі від
звільненого міста продовжує обстрілювати
його сирні касети пускають
перше в житті Якщо чесно я бачила що
таке фосфорні зміни в нормальному житті
тебе подумав що можливо це Салют це
якийсь феєрверк і вони спускаються до
землі такими спалахами і кількома
вибухками і потім з'являється ось це
такі дуже неприємне він і досі в горлі
смак присмак фосфору що це тільки що
було бомби Ну це ж за Ну конечно и часто
таке відбувається
в чому
випалює все що до чого каснеться залізо
желізо здание здание все до нуля випалює
його потушити нереально і сьогодні А
були прильоти в житлові квартали в е-е
житлові будинки де були там пожежі І от
така ситуація
чуємо в Херсоні щодня кожен хто
залишився в нашому місті зараз він
розуміє свою небезпеку і він приймає
рішення за себе що він залишається в
небезпечному місці ми розуміємо в якій
складній ситуації знаходяться наші
громадяни тут надіємося і будемо
працювати зараз дати з міністерствами і
з місцевою Владою для того щоб дав
гуманітарна допомога яка надається
міжнародними організаціями все-таки
доходила до кожного Хто тут сьогодні її
максимально потребує і це було зроблено
в якийсь прозорий швидкий зрозумілий
спосіб для того щоби люди не нарікали І
тільки так чекали Україну все-таки
отримали максимально від України Але
одночасно звичайно Будемо далі
продовжувати нашу роботу на міжнародному
напрямку тому що нам потрібно багато
серйозної зброї для того щоб вигнати
орків із лівого берега Дніпра і більше
саме далекобійною зброєю щоб все ж таки
діти і люди в Херсоні в Херсонщині не
чули і швидше звільнили інші берег
Дніпра і для того щоб Ми повернули всю
землю і всіх людей які так чекають
визволення нас жовто-блакитний прапор
орки замальовувались своїм тепер там уже
так перемалювати на жовто-блакитний
будет коричневий Ну ми його перемалюємо
на чорна червоний а наші пори поряд
намалюємо нашу жовте синій тут повинна
все бути жовта синім все і я сподіваюсь
і Влада у нас буде жовта синя місто
після окупації дуже відчувається що тут
ніхто не сказав про чудове українське
місто його треба ще приводити до ладу і
звичайно багато людей залишилося без
роботи залишилися сьогодні без засобів
існування тому ідея встановлення
хлібопекарні яка би могла давати там 600
кг хлібу на зміну це важливо чому ми на
цьому хлібі наполягали ми розуміємо що
ми все місто не на кормимо але все ж
таки це навіть більше ніж просто хліб це
забота а людях люди розуміють що є хтось
хто про них просто подумав і тим більше
дико звучать історію що така
хлібопекарня та може з нею не потрібна
боремося за те щоб все-таки здоровий
глузд і мудрість перемагали хліб для
українців це взагалі не про їжу я так
вважаю те що ми бачимо ми розуміємо це
проблеми з роботою у людей тобто ті які
залишилися і звичайно вони не хочуть
покидати місце і треба Якщо пенсіонер
мають пенсію то молоді люди середнього
віку які працездатні вони хочуть
працювати Вони не хочуть покидати своє
місце місто але їм Необхідно також
допомагати фінансово от сьогодні в
кількох районах були пожежі тому що
падали Осколки цих снарядів були
поранені люди і власне це щодня таке
відбувається в Херсоні слухайте весь час
гускає весь час губкою весь час Ну
нічого нам не страшно ми вже пережили те
що було тут і все добре